an olympic athlete from belarus who
refused to fly home over fears for her
safety
has entered the polish embassy in tokyo
where she's understood to be seeking
asylum
christina simonskaya said she was taken
to tokyo's main airport against her will
after being thrown off the belarus
team she had criticized her coaches
belarusian
officials blamed what they called her
emotional and psychological condition
for that decision the sprinter was due
to compete in the 200 meters
on monday the slovenian and czech
governments have also offered
humanitarian visas for the athlete
after refusing to board her flight
christina zemenov
issued a plea to the international
olympic committee here's what she had to
say
i'm asking the international olympic
committee for help i'm being put under
pressure to leave the country without my
consent
i'm asking the ioc to intervene in this
get more on this story now from
belarusian journalists
uh hannah christina simanowskaya says
she's being put under pressure what kind
of pressure is she talking about
well she was threatened by the
sports leadership of belarus that she
kind of uh has to come back to belarus
she cannot participate in the games
and she's not able to represe represent
the country
now propaganda started a an attack
against her she is being accused of
treason
she's been accused of kind of
making the reputation of the country
really bad making the leadership of the
country looking really bad so that's
kind of a lot of
issues happening right now around
cena in belarus so what is the role of
professional
sports uh in in belarus is it important
for the state
well sports is really important for
alexander lukashenko for years he has
been presenting himself as a chief
athlete
in belarus as you might remember one
year ago when the first wave of the
pandemic started he even said that ice
hockey
is a cure for the coronavirus so he has
built a lot of kind of stadiums a lot of
sports
objects in belarus and he even before
the olympic games started he
warned the sports leadership the
national team that if they don't win any
medals
if there wouldn't be any results those
people would rather not come back to
belarus
so he uses sports as a propaganda
tool in in the country talking about
propaganda how is this being
reported this case being reported by the
state media belarus
so state media is now reporting that it
was basically a
provocation by christina timonoska that
it was planned in advance
that she was trained educated in belarus
and you see how she's now paying back
um and kind of the whole media
propaganda machine repressive machine is
being now launched against
christina i would say and it all forced
her
husband who was still in belarus to
leave the country to flee for ukraine
because he also kind of
he's scared of some prosecution he's
scared of some arrest
he might be held as hostage to make
christina come back to belarus so he
just left
journalist thank you very much